manifestation ce matin des agents de
l'aéroport roissy charles de gaulle à
l'appel de la cgt en cause la question
des salaires malgré un accord trouvé
récemment entre la direction et
plusieurs syndicats
on retrouve tout de suite quelqu'un
pique nique sur place katia la grève
n'est donc pas terminée chez adp et non
pas du tout les grilles comme vous voyez
derrière moi un cortège d'environ 150
personnes se dirigent vers le siège d'à
dp il est escorté par les forces de
police se déroule dans le calme pour le
moment
alors les grèves ont démarré à partir du
1er juillet les une série de blocages et
de manifestation et à la suite de ces
actions est bien adp a signé un
protocole de fin de grève mais seulement
avec les syndicats unsa et cfe cgc
donc la grève est maintenue pour la cgt
et fo que vous voyez derrière moi ils
leur réclament le retrait du plan
d'adaptation des contrats de travail le
plan pacte ces derniers syndicats
estiment que à la suite des négociations
avec adp n'y a pas eu assez de
discussions avec les grévistes qu'il n'y
a pas eu un taj et pour évaluer cet
accord cet accord parlons-en justement
il a fixé la baisse des salaires a pas
plus de 5% en 2021 et 2022 pas plus de
4% en 2023 il prévoit un retour à la
normale salaire de 2019 en 2024 au plus
tard et sans condition mais aujourd'hui
la cgt fo déplore que la suppression de
la clause de mobilité certaine
été réclamée elle a été enlevée mais
pour eux c'est une clause en trompe
l'oeil puisque lé a prévu dans tout
nouveau contrat signé et puis il ya
également la perte de ces indemnités
kilométriques était très importante pour
certains d'entre eux alors il compte
rattraper 2010 ce qu'ils ont perdu
on continue à manifester mais ils
prévoient plutôt une mobilisation forte
pour la rentrée est pour le moment bien
sûr continue à faire pression en se
rendant prédisait la dépêche merci katia
technique pour toutes ces précisions
direct de l'aéroport roissy charles de
gaulle au nord de paris